are you out of your mind here's the
debate you're upset
[Music]
okay today is what episode number
171 with dr patrick moore if you don't
know who dr patrick moore is
uh canadian industry consultant former
activist and past president
of greenpeace canada and he left
and he has a lot to say about climate
change he has a lot to say about uh
anything related to climate change and i
told him before we went live i said look
we have one basic outcome on today's
zoom today's uh podcast it was basic
right it's not like when we're not small
little things we're gonna smoke
our goal is by the time we're done to
solve every issue in regards to climate
change because it is a big concern so dr
patrick moore thanks for being on the
podcast thank you for having me patrick
very nice to be here yes patrick and
patrick we're going to figure this out
guys yeah like but i said he looks like
a patrick i don't look like a patrick
there's a big difference patrick yes you
will so so you know if you don't mind
for the audience that doesn't know your
full background and what you did to come
about the current philosophies that you
have in regards to climate change would
you mind taking a minute or two and
giving your background to the audience
i grew up on a floating logging camp on
the northwest tip of vancouver island in
the rainforest by the pacific ocean
i didn't realize how lucky i was
surrounded by forests and tide flats and
ocean
rivers
trees everywhere
i didn't realize how lucky i was until i
was sent off to boarding school in
vancouver at age 14.
a very good school where i learned
city ways and also discovered life
science
and that made me realize that i had
always been innately in love with nature
and with life
and i excelled in that went more to the
life science side biology forestry
genetics
human
evolution
all these subjects and i've studied them
ever since
uh that's all i've ever done
while i was at ubc university of british
columbia doing a honors
combined
bachelor of science in
biology and forestry i discovered
ecology
that word had not yet been printed in
the popular press it was
an obscure science word
of course environment was becoming
discussed a lot in the late 60s
when i joined my phd program in ecology
and after about two years
i learned about a small group that had
started to form in vancouver
called the don't make a wave committee
planning a protest voyage across the
pacific to the aleutian islands
to protest u.s hydrogen bomb testing
we took on the world's most powerful
organization the us atomic energy
commission
we're followed by the cia
all the way across the ocean and
arrested by the coast guard so we got on
walter cronkite's evening news
and that was the beginning of what
greenpeace became famous for in those
early years was going to the scene of
the crime
going out into the ocean and getting in
front of the harpoons which i did for
four years in a row
in the summers
and uh it just it was amazing journey
so i spent 15 years in the top committee
of greenpeace
first as a director of the founding
group greenpeace foundation
and then as a an international director
for the last six years i was there
campaigning all around the world
we took on the campaign to stop the
slaughter of a quarter of a million baby
seals still nursing
on the ice flows off canada that was
more of a humanitarian
issue or a human humane issue about
wildlife we wouldn't do that with deer
we wouldn't kill
the babies when they're still nursing
with their mother
so
after that though we really got serious
about toxics
and whereas
i was i was the only
international director with any formal
science education
you don't have to be a marine biologist
to
want to save the whales you don't have
to be a nuclear physicist to want to
stop
nuclear war
but when it comes to chemicals
diseases and toxics and health and
all of that you do need some science
and
two things happened as greenpeace grew
first it grew into more of a business
than a campaigning organization because
now we had 2 000 employees
and we had to raise enough money to pay
them their salaries
so your priorities start to shift a bit
secondly greenpeace decided
to describe humans as the enemies of the
earth
whereas we had started off with a strong
humanitarian vision as well as
environmental the peace in greenpeace is
to stop humans from destroying
themselves with nuclear war
so you had to care about people
but in the end the environmental
movement decided to characterize humans
as the enemies of nature
in other words we're the only evil
species
all the other ones are good
and that's way too much like original
sin for me i'm not a fire and brimstone
kind of guy
i believe that humans are part of nature
well because they are that's why i
believe they're part of nature
and there's way more good people than
there are bad people
i suppose there's bad animals too like
rogue elephants and i know four factors
that's just i've had experience with
some of them but going back to so
greenpeace and and
as a kid were you the kid
that was about saving the planet and
hugging were you a tree hugger were you
the guy that would walk up and see a
tree and you'd hug a tree and you're
like i can't believe they're doing this
to the planet these rich people they're
doing such bad things that made you want
to go join greenpeace like was that kind
of if i was to you know follow you back
and we had content on you at 14 15 16
years old was that you no
my father was the logger
and so was i so were all the people
around me and fisher people too
so we knew that you had to take from
nature in order to survive
and there's simply no question of that
and that's why these campaigns today to
stop using energy
are so stupid because there's eight
billion people
and
so i have a balance about this it's not
a one-sided situation
of course we have to protect the planet
that's what feeds us
but we also have to keep ourselves alive
and people don't understand how how
short of time it takes for you not to
have any food
before you disappear from this life
because nobody's experienced it much in
recent years but we're now facing a
situation
where a huge number of very powerful
organizations and elites at an
international and at national levels are
calling for policies that are basically
a suicide pact
basically
a death wish of some sort
and
it's true there they might not want to
say it out loud but there's a lot of
people who think there's too many people
and i i i think that's ridiculous myself
we're quite well off now than we were
before just 20 years ago we're better
off now with the technology and
and the uh knowledge of the science we
have dr moore you're saying these
organizations or these corporations who
are you referring to you're talking
about the world economic forum uh who
are you referring to well let's start
there yes okay
so you probably have some choice words
for klaus schwab i assume yeah the guy
who said we'll own nothing and be happy
yeah and uh can you put up his picture
so people know what he looks like he's a
sweetheart go ahead yeah it's a it's a
sad situation that we have come to
i didn't realize it could possibly ever
get this serious as i've gone through
like
45 50 years of evolution with this
train of thought
and when climate change first
came up as an issue
i realized
that
we were being duped
and it was all about money
eighty percent of all the science
research in the united states is in
universities
they have basically become money milling
machines getting government grants to
tell the politicians what they want
what the politicians want is stories
that make people afraid
so you're driving down the
freeway in your suv you're afraid you're
killing your grandchildren
that makes you feel guilty that makes
you open your wallet and send a big
check to greenpeace
that the politician then
exaggerates that
in the in the public
the media exaggerates it the activists
exaggerate it
and the scientists are the are the
silent part of it in a way because
nobody sees the money going from the
politicians to the scientists it goes
through bureaucrats
at state city
national international levels
and that money
is meant to create narratives that will
scare people
and that makes them easier to control
it's as simple as that and and then of
course the
the media machine on a global basis now
is one of the most influential and
powerful things in everyone's lives and
some people choose to listen to the lies
that are coming from the mainstream
media
instead of actually interpreting it for
themselves from what they see
like how can there be 25 of the
population in the united states that
thinks biden's doing a good job
how does that happen why is there two
never mind
25 percent of the whole population the
most popular president of all time how
could you say that that's right i forgot
that yeah i shouldn't shouldn't ever
yeah but but okay so but i want i want
to go back to what he's asking so you
know i gotta so while you're asking the
question and you're saying what you're
saying i said
my mind immediately went to
a correlation between population
increasing in the world and
you know temperature climate change all
that stuff and then i want to know what
is the capacity of the most people that
can live in the world so this article
came out can you
zoom in a little bit this is an article
from four years three days ago and i
just come on kind of want to get your
feedback on i literally just looked at
this when he was speaking how many
people can earth support
because i just read an article last week
that says it's projected that we're
going to hit 10 billion by 2050 i don't
know if you saw that or not by 2050
we're going to hit 10 billion okay 10
billion is what roughly 2 billion more
than what we have today give or take
7.87.9 we go to nine point eight nine
point nine two billion more ten billion
okay are we really gonna see the
difference in traffic are we really
gonna see the difference what does that
really mean to us and where we live so
pull up a little bit keep going up so
when you read this it says around three
and i want you to correct if anything
here you i'm reading that the guy got
wrong so
there are nearly 8 billion people living
on earth today but our planet wasn't
always so crowded around 300 000 years
ago when homo sapiens
likely first appeared our total
population was small around 100 to 10
000 people okay
there were so few people at the start
that it took approximately 35 000 years
for the human population to double in
size that's a long time according to
joel e cohen head of laboratory and
populations at the rockefeller
university and columbia university in
new york city
after the invention of agricultural
agriculture between 15 000 and 10 000
years ago
when there were between 1 million and 10
million individuals on earth it took
1500 years
for the human population to double
by the 16th century the time needed the
popu for the population to double
drop to 300 years after the turn of the
century
uh it took more than 130 years go little
in the 19th century from 1930 to 1974
the earth's population doubled again in
just 44 years but is the human
population expected to continue growing
at this rate and is there an upper limit
to how many humans our planet can
support in 1679 and to anthony anthony
van
luen hoke a scientist and inventor
microsoft microscope predicted that
earth could support 13.4 billion people
according to cohen he calculated that
holland occupied one part and thirteen
thousand phone of earth's
uh habitat habitable uh uh habitable
land and so multiplied holland's
population of one million people by
thirteen thousand four hundred over
forty years of research has collected
okay so this is telling us we can we can
handle 13.4 billion but the reality of
it is
there is a capacity and you know there
was a very
legendary song that came out uh
you know 25 years ago
that would say you know me and you are
mammals let's do it like they do on
discovery channels
what is it i think that was a song by
the presidents of the united states of
america but what is the name of how does
it go mammals we can
let's do it like we they do on discovery
channel right
massive hit i don't know if you're
familiar anyways it's a very one-hit
wonder touch but what's that can i read
the lyrics because it's very this is a
very serious conversation so you and me
baby ain't nothing but mammals so let's
do it like they do on discovery channel
this is a fact
danke it's a fact by the bloodhound gang
i apologize this is not going away so
if if we're gonna keep having sex
and most people don't like condoms okay
and there's only so much you can take
nowadays to prevent from pregnancies
unless if you want to be a dictator
saying one child per like china did for
many many years
we're gonna keep continuing to grow
so if we keep continuing to grow is it
something that we just sit there and say
let our great great great great great
however many greats that we have to say
let them deal with this we don't need to
do nothing about it today or do we sit
there and say you know what
i know i'm never going to meet that kid
who's 20 generations away from me but
how about i figure out a way to make
some things a little bit better so his
life is going to be better and he's
going to get an opportunity to do
whatever he's going to at that time yeah
should we look at it from that
perspective well it wouldn't make much
sense if he never got to be there in the
first place would it how are you going
to help him then
you know that's one important question
which means what what which means if you
stopped him from being born
that's a completely different
conversation yeah yeah you went
you and elsewhere which is great we can
get back to that but the only way to
find out how many people the planet can
support is to see how many people the
planet can support i'm not saying i'm in
favor of that but the good news is is
that the wealthier people get the fewer
children they have
and it is projected that the population
will level off perhaps by as soon
as 2050.
africa isn't a bit of an exception it's
projected to continue to grow in
population because and you look how big
africa is to start with it has a pretty
low population for its geographical size
and potential for agriculture at this
point did you just i don't want to cut
you off did you just say the wealthier
people get the less children they tend
to have yes really well it's true in the
in in all the way are you really
surprised or i didn't know
yeah i actually am surprised because i
mean you're having more children these
no no no healthier yoga
yeah i didn't know that they're actually
options process that though process that
process that like because kids cost so
much money you're saying no no no just
think about like look around who has the
most babies
huh mormons religious people okay so but
orthodox jews but look communities look
ethnicities families look like you know
who has the most kids you know certain
communities you can go into and say my
gosh you have nine kids hey i grew up in
a family with this many kids so that is
true
the more the more money you make the
less kids most people want to have
interesting yeah that seems a little
counterintuitive because it costs a
quarter million dollars i would have 20
00 to 18 statistically that's that most
of the wealthier countries have negative
population growth just given their own
internal populations
most of those countries populations are
only growing because of immigration
that's when you say wealthier countries
i mean who are the wealthiest countries
western europe united states united
states china and south korea china's if
you look at the per capita uh wealth of
china it's nowhere near the wealthier
countries
per capita there are rich people there's
lots of billionaires there but that's
because there's so many people there
it's just a fact that the wealthier
people get
the i just pulled up the 20 countries
with the highest population growth
in 2021 and it validates what you're
saying wow very interesting 20 i think
it's like 20 out of 20 countries are all
if you can look this up third world
countries you're saying no it's africa
specifically iran africa that's what
he's talking about please continue
so i i don't think you know
there's been a lot of discussion about
this all through recent history
about whether or not there should be
some effort to curb
the growth of human population that
requires draconian rules such as the one
child policy which china has now
eliminated they've
they've realized that was not a good
idea because people
were purposefully killing girl children
in order that they could have a boy
so uh
and pat cites all the time that india's
population is growing average pages
average age in india is 26.4 27 years
old exactly they're at 38 we're at 36.
but the china's another one of the most
interesting things so i mean i see
there's there's really two main sides to
this whole story of climate change
and that is the climate change issue
itself
the the climate of the earth and the
energy issue
those are two sides of the same coin
because it's energy that's being blamed
for the climate emergency which is a
total hoax there is no climate
emergencies where you start with that
one and i could go on for a long time
about that
but you've got a teenage girl from
sweden coming out
in front of the united nations as if
she's some kind of expert on what's
going to happen in the next hundred
years
with the climate of the earth which is
about one of the most complicated
systems there is in the universe i mean
there are so many factors involved and
even the intergovernmental panel on
climate change which is the supreme
international body on the subject
has twice stated in its full reports
that because the climate is
multifactorial in other words there are
many factors involved
non-linear in other words these aren't
in straight lines
these factors have all kinds of
different formulas
that you can't just predict a straight
line out of any of them
and most importantly
the climate is chaotic
and chaotic is a mathematical word it
means you can't see through it it means
it's unpredictable
like the turbulence in front of a boat
that is chaos
because you can't predict the shape that
those bubbles are going to go in
it's it's chaotic
and so they say therefore future climate
states cannot be predicted they say that
and yet then they go ahead and predict
them with computer models which is like
pretending you have a crystal ball
the crystal ball is a mythical object
you cannot predict the future with a
crystal ball because it doesn't actually
exist
but these computers do exist
but everybody knows garbage in garbage
out
so as if you put your own assumptions
into a computer model it will come out
with the answer you wish to have every
single time if you put the same numbers
into a computer model a million times
a million times you'll get exactly the
same result it's just a machine
it is not an intelligent being even and
intelligent beings have realized that
because the climate is chaotic it's
impossible to predict it
we can go back in time and we can go
back half a billion years in time with
sediment cores from the bottom of the
ocean
where you can see
elements and isotopes which can tell you
what the temperature was a hundred
million years ago and tell you what the
atmospheric concentration of co2 was 200
million years ago we have that to look
at so we can look at the history of the
earth with many factors
and see how it's been behaving
and we know it's behaving in a way that
does not link carbon dioxide to
temperature
they are actually slightly negatively
correlated in the long historical record
in other words it is not a cause effect
relationship
there is some cause effect relationship
between temperature and co2 and that has
occurred during the last two and a half
million years which is the pleistocene
ice age this is the irony of this whole
situation the world is colder now
during this last two and a half billion
years
than it had been for the previous 250
million
there was no ice on either pole
for 250 million years
the previous ice age was called a keru
it lasted from 350 to 250 million years
ago in other words it lasted for a
hundred million years that doesn't make
any sense to me so let me challenge you
on that okay so you said that that ice
age happened when and it lasted for 150
how many years
100 million 100 million years and it was
uh it was called a keru k r k a r double
o how long ago was that
it began 350 million years ago and ended
250 million years ago and it's in
wikipedia and everywhere else no no i'm
not questioning that that didn't exist
but what doesn't make any sense is what
then when that did happen
how many people were living on the
planet 350 million years ago modern life
was well established at that time four
forests were established
animals were established insects were
established all the sea life was already
established how about humans like how
about us it doesn't matter we're a
mammal but wait a minute i'm asking you
a question it doesn't matter no it's
context no let me tell you why it
doesn't because yourself myself and all
of us in this room yeah and everybody in
this world and all the animals and
plants
all came from then no that's not what
i'm asking no no you wouldn't be here if
if it wasn't of course listen you're on
a podcast that you're going to get
challenged if you're uncomfortable with
it i'm going to keep challenging you so
you can challenge me i'm comfortable
with this i'm ready so so going back to
it so at
do you think if i talk on my phone for
12 hours straight every day for two
years you think that radiation is going
to hurt me a little bit
no you don't think it's gonna hurt me at
all no okay do you think the whole thing
with radiations being near
uh plants nuclear plants or you know the
the wiring you know how uh uh
5g you're talking about not
just going straight up like if you live
close to
plants that have a lot of uh uh
radiation you think that's bad for you
and i no at all zero okay no because
they don't have a lot of radiation
they're shielded and they have less
radiation than standing near a granite
wall in many cases granite has radiation
do you think a guy who works near
choppers and planes
there are side effects that's going to
hurt his hearing over a time of 10 20
years only if he gets hit by the
propeller
there's gonna be
hearing i was in the army myself and
they would say wear these things because
if you okay but sometimes eventually
there's some side effects to it right
okay
there's no way i can compare
how peaceful a building was
with nobody working and living in it
versus how peaceful a building is with
200 people living in that building
there's going to be more things breaking
with 200 people living in a building
than when that building was built up and
nobody's living in it there's going to
be things that's going to happen there's
going to be deterioration because we're
going to naturally do that when i bought
my house my house was
brand spanking new clean white walls all
this stuff come take a look at some of
the white walls see what my four kids
have done okay the other i'm like jim
what is this all about baby i don't even
know how they broke that okay we got to
get it fixed right okay so i'm not
sitting here saying
it's your climate change is real but i'm
saying if i'm going to match data to
data
you can't say data to data and there's
no human you know mankind living here
versus there's mankind living today i
don't know i'm this is not my world i'm
not a doctor i'm not a scientist i'm not
a phd i'm a person that questions things
to wonder there has to be some kind of
correlation here with what we're doing
to hurt this if we are in any possible
way so when you say that and you say ice
age all this stuff i'm like come on but
we were not around
so we came around things have changed
ever since mankind started producing
things
you could look at dubai what dubai
looked like 40 years ago you ever seen a
picture what dubai looks like today it
ain't the same place
to completely different place so we have
some kind of an impact on it my question
becomes is the following
um
what's the capacity in this building
how many people hundred people hundred
people okay but how about if we really
are super cheap and we want to max this
place out 200 people 200 people can we
have 500 people working in this building
hell no is it no or hell no
it is hell no it is hell no i agree with
you
they're happy we have a nice building
just for the record it's not what i'm
saying it has nothing to do with nice
but we have a nice uh you know planet
that we're living in
what's our capacity and what kind of a
negative impact are we making into it if
any that's my curiosity yeah cities
occupy about 2.5 of the land on the
earth and the land is only 25 of the
earth the other 75 percent is the ocean
where very few people are living
so we have actually the people who live
in the cities
think the whole world is a city i think
i think they never go outside to see
what's out there or fly over it to see
what's underneath how many farms and
forests there are across the united
states of america i've flown over every
country in the world practically let me
give you one example europe the whole of
europe like the eu
200 years ago
was down to less than 10 forest
they had
been using wood
but this is before fossil fuels were
used extensively so they were using wood
for all their energy for heating all
their buildings for making steel and
copper and glass
and steam engines so they had started to
deplete the forests and the forests
weren't growing back naturally as fast
as they were being cut for industry and
heating
and so silviculture was born the science
of growing forests and whereas
agriculture started about 10 000 years
ago growing food it was not necessary to
learn how to grow trees because there
were so many of them and so few people
that up until then no one had learned
how to farm trees
so silviculture began in central europe
in the eastern part
and today
europe has 43 percent forest cover
more than four times nearly five times
what it had 200 years ago and that is
the result of humans
farming trees and the trees are native
trees
in in some countries they farm trees
that come from other countries where
they call them exotic trees like in
south america for example there are
really no native trees that are good for
forestry because they grow too slowly
new zealand is the same a lot of the
southern hemisphere has forests that
grow very slowly but they can import
pines from california in new zealand and
monterey pine and develop a huge forest
industry and exporting wood to japan and
china by the score and at the same time
creating a forest where there wasn't one
before because it had been turned into a
grassland with sheep on it and that's
why new zealand has so many sheep
because it wasn't worth growing trees
back on the land after you fell the
trees for wood so they brought in sheep
now they're putting those same pastures
back to forest in many cases china and
india have produced more new forest
cover in the last 50 years than all the
rest of the world put together
and in fact china and india are between
the two of them emitting more than 50
percent of all the carbon dioxide
in the world today
therefore they are contributing to the
most to the fertilization of the air
with co2 to grow more food crops and
forests that's why there's record
harvests every year about 70 percent of
the increase in our food crops are
are because of additional carbon dioxide
and when so now i'm i want to talk a
little bit about this this the science
side
of the climate stuff because
a piece of wood
is made from air
only about one percent of it comes from
the rocks
the rest of it comes from carbon
hydrogen oxygen and nitrogen
all of which are invisible gases in the
atmosphere so life its foundation of
life is taking its material from the
atmosphere not from the ground people
think trees are eating the soil trees
make the soil
if it wasn't for the trees it would just
be bare rocks
so the trees are actually producing the
soil by taking gases from the atmosphere
the nitrogen has to come through
nitrogen-fixing bacteria in the soil
but it originates from the atmosphere
are you saying that deforestation is not
a major concern like for instance a lot
of friends who in miami here who are
from brazil and if any time you hear
about brazil bolsonaro the president of
brazil he gets a lot of flack for
the deforestation of what they're doing
to brazil you see you know in the amazon
trees getting burnt down you know making
way for
more cities and more people are you
saying that that's not a big major issue
the amazon is called a human desert
because there's so few people there
hardly any brazilians ever get to go to
the amazon and so they're easily duped
with propaganda about what's happening
there i've flown over it twice five
hours it takes to fly over the amazon
it's practically as as big as half of
north amer half the lower 40 48 states
it's a huge area
less than 10 percent of it has been
converted to farmland
the rest of it is still forested
that is a fact
and so i've actually toured
the whole of brazil i went there from
british columbia
because british columbia where i'm from
that came to be a huge anti-forestry
movement in a province where forestry is
the primary industry
and growing trees back
so i went to brazil because they were
calling bc the brazil of the north
as if we were destroying all our forests
just like brazil was in british columbia
yeah in british columbia yeah
and in canada in general there was a big
movement greenpeace after i left it
started a big movement to ban canadian
forest products in all of europe because
we export a lot of forest products to
europe seeing as though we have the
second most number of forests in the
whole world the united states actually
has the largest forest industry in the
world
and the u.s south
produces most of
most of that wood but again coming back
to the
the
hardly imaginable fact that wood is made
with air
you're going a different angle i want to
go a complete different angle go there i
want to go a complete different angle
and i really want you to help me out
here so
based on your research
what is the matter you said two and a
half percent of the city right
i'm staying on this population topic
what is the maximum capacity of human
beings that can live
on earth
and
we can coexist and everything is
sustainable without it being you know
insanity what's the number nobody has a
clue well i think we do have a clue no
we we don't you but how do you make a
formula but how do you if that's your
world it's to me if okay let's do basic
math formula what do you mean how do we
have a clue the way i would do it i
would say okay
where can't men live okay so maybe let's
just say percentage is a mountain
certain struggle like you can't live in
mount everest you can take those
mountains how many square feet is that
okay how many square miles that let's
take this out okay the world has how
many total square miles here's how many
square miles we have fantastic how much
of it is water take that out how much of
it is this take that out okay so we're
really living with this many square
miles and then what is a too congested
it's new york a level of congestion
healthy no what is a healthy level of
congestion how about we do la la is
congested four or five is pretty bad but
new york is horrible can we do every
city like new york no okay but give me
that formula anyways that if every city
in the world look like new york city we
can handle 22 billion people i don't
know but i know we can figure out that
mathematical formula so then what that
does to me is the following here's what
i do again purely thinking like an
analytics guy that's a financial guy can
you zoom into this real quick for me
zoom in so the rest of the people
watching this as well can see it okay so
this go go a little bit more so we can
see it okay this is world population by
your go down city can see what the top
top no no the other way where the tops
is what it is okay
world vomiter world population by year
2020 we had around 7.794 billion people
okay
go down to when it was 3.7 million 3.7
billion
okay so 3.7 billion was 1971 which is
exactly 50 years ago was 3.7 billion go
down to see when it was 1.9 billion okay
stop 1927 what is the difference between
1927 and 1971 that's what 44 years
that's exactly 44 years so watch this it
doubled in 44 years then it doubled in
50 years so it dropped around 10
15 a drop okay go down c from 1.9
billion when it was a billion okay one
point no no one bill 1.9 okay so it was
a billion went 1804 to 1927 is what holy
[ __ ] that's 123 years okay so it's crazy
it took a long time to double there
between a billion and a half billion was
1600
so that took how many years 196 years
250 billion is what
900 that's how many years 700 years keep
going lower keep going lower keep going
lower so 900 if you go to
you get the idea what i'm doing with the
math here at 5 000 the bc before christ
was 5 million people so we went in the
last 7 000 years from 5 million people
to 8 billion people if i double that if
i double that here's what it looks like
let's double it let's play rule of 72.
how many years is that seven thousand
years seven thousand years oh let's
double it so 5 million goes what 10
million 20 million 40 million 80 million
163 20 640 1 to 1.28 billion 2.56
billion 5.12 billion 10 billion that's
11 doubles okay 10 doubles is what we're
looking at it took 10 doubles only to go
from 5 million people
to eight billion people
in seven thousand years okay
that to me i sit there and i say the
following i say
al gore is full of [ __ ]
i say aoc is definitely full of [ __ ] the
end of the world is in 12 years full of
[ __ ] but guess what
it is happening eventually if we don't
do something about it the end of the
world not the end of the world the end
of human population group the the end of
the capacity what our capacity will be
so
then we can think like dr evil i can
tell you one thing that explains why
there went from four billion to eight
billion for example why it's called the
haber bosch process it won two nobel
prizes in the early nineteen hundreds it
was a formula
a technological uh process
involving very high heat and very high
pressure an extremely complicated
process which was able to combine
nitrogen from the atmosphere with
natural gas to make ammonia
that ammonia is the basis of all the
nitrogen fertilizer being used in the
world's agriculture today it results in
at least a doubling of crop production
and that is why we see this news today
about sri lanka banning
nitrogen fertilizer and netherlands now
basically banning much of the nitrogen
fertilizer and this is the biggest
threat we have right now to an immediate
starvation situation in the world food
shortage you hear it said that's where
i'm going the odd time yeah but the
reason it's it self-inflicted
this food shortage
nitrogen the air has 70 percent of the
air is a nitrogen we could take nitrogen
out of the air for the next million
years and make fertilizer because it all
goes back into the air again eventually
same with the carbon dioxide
we talk about ourselves emitting all
this carbon dioxide
what are we emitting it from oh fossil
fuels oh where did they come from
they came from life absorbing carbon
from the atmosphere as carbon dioxide
and being deposited in sediments called
oil gas and coal so when we put co2 in
the atmosphere we're just putting it
back where it came from in the first
place that's why co2 was so much higher
in the atmosphere in past
millennia like it's gone from 2500 ppm
to 180 ppm 20 000 years ago
in 150 million years that's a long time
but it's been a steady downward trend of
co2 in the global atmosphere
for 500 million years
there's been a couple of dips and ups
and downs but basically it's a downward
trend and that's because the carbon
has been taken from the atmosphere as
carbon dioxide which is the only way
life can get carbon it's the only source
of carbon for life and all life is
carbon based that's why they call it the
chemistry of carbon organic chemistry
and the chemistry of all other elements
in organic chemistry
so what we've got here is a situation
where people just don't understand that
there is no historical relationship
between the level of co2 in the
atmosphere and the temperature of the
earth but that's not where i'm going
though but that's what the climate
change issue is that's not i'm not a
climate change guy i i think both you
and bill and i have problems
i think both of you are bad for society
really let me explain to you why because
both of you are way too confident
and that i don't i don't trust that i'm
not i'm just going by date of the day
but he says the same thing but he says
the same thing he says i'm also going
based off of data no he doesn't well he
takes a fire extinguisher and points it
on a globe of the earth right i don't do
that sort of but but to me you seem way
too confident as well the level of the
level of certainty and scientists
concerns me too much on both sides so
i'm questioning the following but i
don't have a level of certainty because
i said very clearly that we can't
predict the future of the climate
i'm looking at the past we know the past
so i i can be confident about what's in
the past record but the past record
during the time where we did not exist
does not make any sense in the argument
we're making because we had no influence
over it back then we do today
it's not about influence about we can
measure impact we can measure through
sediment cores in the ocean floor we can
go back half a billion years in terms of
the chemistry of the earth in the
atmosphere i don't think you understand
what my point is i think you can go get
that data yes based on what you're
saying we got it but that data doesn't
exist if we that data it doesn't mean
anything
if we were not there to show any direct
negative impact we're making into it
that's my question so if you say well
let me tell you something here's what
happened to the world during this time
do we exist no okay so now we do and
there's 8 billion of us now and if we've
doubled 10 times in the last 7 000 years
do you know what two doubles is
let me ask you if something doubles ten
times do you think it's a big deal if
something levels two times no what's two
doubles you know what two doubles is
two doubles is 32 billion people you
mean to tell me the world can handle 32
billion people i didn't say that but do
you think it can so to me eventually i
have no idea patrick as what will be
invented in the next 50 years or 100
years so but but but we have to sit
there and think okay so we have to sit
there and say if that is the case
if we're going there if math shows us
we have not stopped going like right now
the market crashed right i think the
market's going to crash pretty bad the
next 6 12 24 months i think it's gonna
be very ugly
and i agree a lot of people are gonna
get hurt in a very big way do you know
what i think is gonna happen in five to
ten years market's gonna go dow's gonna
hit 60 000 in the next 10 15 years okay
what do you think is going to happen in
the next five years we're going to have
a trillionaire what do we think is going
to happen in the next 20 years we're
going to have 10 trillionaire i mean
that's going to keep happening right and
in the market in the climate change
stuff it was oh but look what's going on
today
i don't care what's going on today i
want to see the difference of what's
happened last 50 years
oh what's going on this year look what
happened to the temperatures give me a
hundred years which i kind of you know
go back to your argument what i'm asking
right now is
if we double two more times we got 32
billion people here we can't have 32
billion people in this in the world in
other words we won't double it
to 32. if we can't have it we won't go
there why we can't get okay so let's
let's speculate tell me what you mean by
that what i mean is today people are
getting wealthier the number of people
living in poverty as a percentage of the
population is much smaller now than it
was 20 30 50 years ago
when we reach a position
where more and more people are going
into poverty and starving to death we
will know we're coming close to that
limit
how else are you going to find out
unless you artificially reduce the
population by cutting off the fossil
fuels and by cutting off the nitrogen
fertilizer that's what the real problem
is today this is i'm saying this is a
self-inflicted wound that we are dealing
with right now
and it's a it's a real problem because
i
i can see this that these powerful
elites like schwab and on down they want
control of the world they want control
of everybody now what do they want they
want fewer people they think it's
already too many i think that's what
they've been saying in the united
nations for a long time but the facts
don't bear that out because less and
less people are living in poverty and
our knowledge of agriculture is growing
our knowledge of genetics is growing and
we're able to grow way more food now
than we were then and food is the basis
of how many people can be here now the
environmental side of that is a
different matter but as i've pointed out
we are not losing the world's forests
there's no there's a few places where
deforestation is still an issue but
there's not very many even in africa
they are growing their forests back in
the saheel now you know
people don't realize that the sahara
desert was lush with grass all during
the first part of this holocene
interglacial for five thousand years
there were goat herders and villages you
can see the red dots on a map of where
these villages were all across the
sahara so the climate has changed long
before humans could have been any factor
in it it's been changing all through the
history of the earth
there was as i say an ice age
hundreds of millions of years ago and
now we're in another ice age and the
irony is that people think it's getting
too hot when we're in one of the coldest
periods in earth's history right now
this is an interglacial period in
between
there's been like 40 plus
major glacial periods during this glyce
this ice age people think the ice age
ended 20 000 years ago that was just
number 42 or 43 in terms of glacial
advance where the whole of canada and
russia are covered in ice and all of
northern europe
that melted took 10 000 years for that
to melt and for the last ten thousand
years we've been in this relatively
benign climate called the holocene
interglacial period
during which the ice has retreated at
least up to the arctic ocean
twenty thousand years ago the whole of
canada was covered in a mile or more of
ice
imagine if that happens again which if
history repeats itself it will because
it's happened 44 times before this and
they were in different periods some were
42 000 year periods others were hundred
thousand year periods the most recent
ones have been in hundred thousand year
periods we know this from ice cores
taken from antarctica and greenland
which go back hundreds of thousands of
years they can see what the co2 was they
can see what the temperature was they
can see a whole bunch of other things
and they show us these patterns of
climate that have been occurring
so it's very clear to me that the human
contribution to climate is virtually
minimal
if at all the main thing we need to
worry about is the ecosystems of the
oceans and the lands and the forests and
how much land we put in farmland and how
we can make farmland be conducive to
bird life and
other life i mean farmers don't really
like any other life other than the thing
they're growing they don't like weeds
they don't like insects they don't like
birds but in forestry
the foresters don't care about those
things very much there are some insects
that kill forests but mostly foresters
love birds and animals and plants what
percentage of the world is farmland and
forest you know i don't know exactly no
but
the farmland
is there's two types of farmland there's
land that's plowed arable land and then
there's grazing land and often the
grazing land also has a lot of trees on
it and a lot of other plants on it so
it's it's more natural can you pull that
up i just typed in what percentage of
the world is farmland and forest
just type in what percentage of the
world is uh now if you do it on google
it'll actually give you the percentage
right off the bat yeah what percentage
of the world is
actually type in the word
what percentage of the world is farmland
what percentage of the world is farmland
and forest yeah
and it should say right up there 38 or
something zoom in a little bit
okay so global trends global agriculture
land is approximately 5 billion hectare
hectare
hectares
and 38 the global land surface about one
third of the uh this is used as cropland
and the remaining two thirds consist of
meadows
and pastures for grazing livestock okay
so doc question for you so ten percent
of the land is used for for plowing and
growing crops
monocultures let me ask you a question
how low can we take that percentage down
to
well actually it has been reduced
considerably by two factors in the last
hundred and hundred or so years one
is the invention of the internal
combustion engine and vehicles which
replaced farm animals there was a time
when farm animals used 25 of all the
farmland to grow food for the animals
so now we can use that 25 for growing
food for people
and using we're using fossil fuels to
produce the energy to do the farming
so that's one thing and the other thing
is fertilizer and genetics
the the advances in the science of
agriculture
[Music]
if it hadn't been for the haber-bosch
process there would only be half as many
people on the earth today according to
some people who look at look at that we
wouldn't be able to grow enough food to
feed 8 billion people if we hadn't had
the nitrogen fertilizer because along
with carbon
being the basis of life nitrogen is the
basis of proteins enzymes dna
a whole lot of important
elements in our bodies and so nitrogen
is is as essential in a way as carbon is
and hydrogen and oxygen those are the
main ones
and uh and interestingly they they all
come from the air and water
yeah i guess i guess my question is so
i'm just asking such a mathematical
question that i'm not even going into
the carbon because you want to see the
carbon
debate on a bunch of different videos
you can go watch a ton of them my
concern is math okay so
innovation as well what do capitalists
and entrepreneurs do innovators go out
there and say what there's a problem
here's how we can fix it
here's how much money i can make in it
great i'm willing to fix that you need
this need no problem here's what i'm
going to do and i'm going to make this
much money cool
so
but if is there a level
where are we going to get to a point
where food's going to be
man-made are we going to get to a point
where food's going to be
like you know what's this new meat
they're making the best
beyond meat is that the direction we're
going are we going a direction well we
don't need any farms well we don't need
any because man can officially you know
make food ourselves and we don't need to
go to these places okay and then
that so-called meat is made from plants
i mean you still need farms okay so how
much of this can we not go without like
if it's 38
of the world
is
so global and land surface
is cropland
and the remaining two-thirds of that is
metals and pastures how low can we take
that 38 because people are going to say
what if we can build this here what if
we can build that here how low can we
afford to take that 38 too we're growing
twice as much food on less land now than
we did 50 years ago so that's innovation
so that's progress okay and and at
greenhouse growing
uh
if you fly over south korea it's amazing
nearly every valley is covered in glass
and uh it it's really quite a sight but
greenhouse growing is not only because
you can make them warmer
greenhouse growers all pump co2 into
their greenhouses to double and triple
it from the atmospheric level of 420 ppm
up to 800 and 1200 ppm and they get 20
to 60 percent increase in yield and
growth inside the greenhouse and you can
also grow without soil in greenhouses
hydroponic agriculture is hugely
successful
so
there's no doubt in my mind that
unless we have a political collapse
of the world uh and a self-inflicted
collapse of the world by banning things
that are necessary for life to exist
uh that we could
theoretically have way more people than
we have now i'm not saying i'm in favor
of that i'm just saying that
theoretically it's feasible with
especially that greenhouse growing is
just getting really off the ground now
worldwide and you can grow twice three
four times as much food on the same area
of land as you can in conventional
agriculture well let me let me let me
ask you a crazy question so when
somebody becomes a president or prime
minister
how much do they care how the economy in
that country does
during the eight years they're the
president versus how the country does
100 years later
well
at this point it doesn't seem like many
presidents especially in the
english-speaking world give a damn about
the eight years they're in power
i mean we've got a ski instructor ski
board instructor running canada we've
got a half demented person here with a
vice president that can't string two
words together properly running the
united states of america
boris johnson thankfully is gone but
who's going to replace him and the
australia has just brought in this weird
government colombia has brought a weird
guy as well they're just bringing weird
people left and right i guess the
qualification is
to become a man in powers to be a little
bit weird maybe that's what they're
looking for i just don't understand why
there aren't more qualified people
seeking these positions but then again
maybe not many people actually want to
heat no not not just the heat it's it's
a
fear it's the freedom it's life is a lot
easier then let them deal with the
problem i guess the point i'm trying to
make to use the following how many
people that become president sit there
and say
i want to create policies
that 10 presidents from now
makes america a better country or how
many presidents get up and say hey mary
can you tell me my approval rating this
morning oh [ __ ] okay let's go tell them
we're going to give a billion dollars of
subsidies to papa papa oh watch but went
up to 41 you're no longer the worst
president of all time like meaning what
i'm trying to say is
how many presidents actually give a [ __ ]
about what's going to happen 100 years
you're not going to bring up the t word
are you what's the t word
the next letter is r
trump no no no no is that a bad word in
your mind no it isn't because i ask
people not why do you hate him
why what policies that he brought in
during his tenure do you disagree with
and
i don't know what the answer can be he
he the policies he brought in
were about the future and we're about
the economy and we're about the people
and we're about to see the southern
border and we're about energy
independence and we're about whatever
i don't know of a bad policy that he
passed and biden comes in and just rubs
them all out with a stroke of a pen on
the first day and causes an energy
disaster and an afghan disaster
afghanistan disaster and all these other
disasters and he still has 25 approval
rating i mean that's a good thing
because that means he has 75 not good
approval rating but
i just don't understand why
the hate happened
i i it it makes no sense to me because
hate is not a good reason to be against
a person uh especially if they haven't
done anything wrong
and
it's been proven eight or ten times over
that he didn't do anything illegal or
wrong but they went after him like as if
he had
robbed the bank you know and
i i
i am very unpopular for even ever
mentioning his name even in my own
country of canada oh we talk about him
all the time you're you're in safe space
here but we'll get back to that because
he's got some things he'll say too about
that but let me let me finalize the
point i was trying to make here's do you
know what point i'm trying to make the
point i'm trying to make i think i want
to know how many people can live on
earth if we keep going this direction
might that not what yeah so my point is
the following here's my point no matter
what country you look at when it comes
down to elections how many of those
presidents are concerned about what the
country's legacy is going to be 50 years
from no it's zero they care about their
18. well that's left or right i think
what you're getting at whether you're
not whether you're this is any country
in the world of course you care about
your power now
zero to do with left right middle zero
this is not like this is why we need a
libertarian president i'm not doing that
at all all i'm saying is the current
structure of any leadership in any
country is what how is the market going
to do well i'm there right okay isn't
that the same for any ceo though
quarterly earnings that's how the
companies not founders ceos yes not
founders because founders live forever
ceos don't okay founders live for you
can't you can't name every ceo of
mcdonald's but you can name the founders
sure right you can't name you you you
found you can name the founding fathers
you're going to forget a lot of the
presidents if i told you who's the 19th
president you may not get it right but
if i tell you who's a founding father
you're probably going to get it right so
so the point i'm trying to make saying
the founding fathers have a vision the
ceos are more concerned with that
quarterly or any learning if they're
watching what's going on are devastated
because they're founders they're like
dude we put this together for it to work
and you guys are breaking this thing
founding father founders are different
but this is the point so if you look at
right now
worst case scenario according to the
math
that we just did
when is the next double going to be
when are we going to go from 8 billion
to sixteen billion
forty years i believe okay so worst case
how many years sixty years what's 60
years from today 20 80. and how long
will it take to double again after that
we don't know so but but we based on
data you keep going back to data it's
not based on data you're projecting the
future by past data and you just use a
bunch of past but i didn't predict the
future but you have to predict the
future no you can't but no no it's not
you can't you can't but you may be wrong
you can that's what visionaries do
you're more than likely to be wrong well
george orwell
somehow got it right yeah some people do
get it right in 1984 when it was wrong
when he wrote the book a lot of people
said he's a fraud exactly okay so let's
play the game of let's forecast and see
what could potentially happen and it's
okay if we get it wrong just like george
well got it right if we do forecast
in 60 years we're at 16 billion if we do
forecast and i'm comfortable being wrong
in 120 years we're at 32 billion you
won't know whether you were wrong or not
i don't care if i know
the human species but it ceased to exist
so because we won't be here i'm in the
insurance business i'm in the insurance
i sell life insurance okay all right
do you know what age you're going to die
i don't know what age i'm going to die
nobody does nobody does but guess what
it's better off having it in case you do
that so your family is protected yeah so
i want to sit there and say okay for the
people that are using tactics to win
elections today
that's not climate change shouldn't be
the number one priority of any campaign
should it be a top 10 thing that we pay
attention to that we have to figure out
a way not even the word climate change
is not even on my priority it's what's
the plan to know what the capacity of
this you know planet is what is our
capacity we need to know those numbers
what number can we not touch is energy
on your priority
in regards to like you're talking cobalt
and what's going on in congo
i mean just in general
without energy nothing moves sure and
without energy there's no heat okay or
cold because air conditioning sure
depends on it too
so
what we have here is if even though you
might not think climate change is an
important issue and i don't either as a
matter of fact because i don't know if i
can do anything about it i think it's a
top ten i don't think it's number one no
it's it well it's a top ten in people's
minds but the the real issue is energy
because the the climate policy that is
being adopted that's a better word i'm
with you there i'm more on the energy
side but we have to pay attention to
this because yes if we don't pay
attention to this this could be an issue
in the next 200 years but the it's the
energy side that will that i'm talking
about being basically a suicide pact is
net zero thing
and
the whole idea that we can end the use
of fossil fuels without increasing
nuclear energy because the same people
who are against all fossil fuel use are
also against all nuclear energy and that
is the only technology that can actually
replace fossil fuels as a reliable
source 24 7. hydroelectric is just as
good except there's flat places and dry
places where there can't be any
hydroelectric energy whereas nuclear is
can be used anywhere from the north pole
to the equator out on the oceans on a
barge you can put nuclear energy
anywhere in the world all you need to do
is cool it with water or air and you can
have it there and the russians are
floating barges down the rivers from the
north in the arctic to the some of the
cities that don't have a grid that are
way up north like they purposely
developed up there
and they're bringing nuclear reactors in
there russia china and india are all way
ahead of the united states now in
nuclear reactor technology
and britain is even further ahead too in
many ways there they've got uh
boeing there and not boeing sorry uh i'm
trying to think of other people who made
it right really expensive cars
um
what is the most expensive british car
rolls-royce rolls-royce yes it's
rolls-royce that has been building the
submarine nuclear engines for
uh uk fleet for 60 years or more they
know how to do it and so the the fact of
the matter is
we could replace 50 percent of the
fossil fuels in the next 30 years or 40
years with nuclear energy with no
difficulty at all but the idea that wind
and solar are going to replace fossil
fuels or nuclear or hydroelectric
is absolutely insane can i just explain
a little bit
when you have wind and solar you have at
most one third
of the of the time can you produce
reliable energy the sun goes down all
night it's no good early in the morning
or the afternoon and then the clouds
come right so solar energy is more like
20 percent capacity
so so 80 of the time it can't serve the
grid which is a demand for energy at
certain times a day a certain amount the
same with wind the wind stops at night
the wind stops in the summer the wind
stops in the winter the wind stops for
two weeks at a time
the wind stops when the propellers
freeze up the wind stops when the wind
the wind blows too fast because they
have to tether the blades
and so if you're going to use batteries
instead of gas
or coal or nuclear
to back up
the wind and solar
you have to build three times as much
capacity
in production in other words if you need
a hundred megawatts
of
coal energy you need 300 megawatts
capacity of wind and solar energy to
charge the batteries because you can't
charge the batteries when the wind isn't
blowing and the sun isn't shining but at
the same time as you're charging the
batteries you have to be supplying the
grid with the full amount of energy that
it needs
so there's no technical feasibility
study on this there's no economic
feasibility study on this mark mills of
the manhattan institute in new york is
the expert he's written three or four
recent papers on how much material it's
going to take in terms of cement the
wind industry
uses more than 100 times as much cement
per unit of power produced as gas does a
hundred times more cement so the amount
of fossil fuels that are required to
build the wind and solar infrastructure
makes wind and solar a parasite on the
larger economy
that is a fair metaphor a parasite in
other words it's sucking
wealth out of the system in order to
support this stupid idea that wind and
solar are renewable yes the sun is
renewable and the wind is renewable but
the infrastructure is not
the stuff they build isn't made out of
plants it's made out of steel and
concrete and cadmium and aluminum and
glass and lithium and cobalt and all
these things and if you look at the
amount of material that has to go into a
wind turbine
compared to a gas plant
it's phenomenal it means they have to
mine vast amounts of ore and truck all
this stuff everywhere huge machinery to
put these things up and build them so
i've said that all the wind and solar
infrastructure onshore and offshore
should have to be built with wind and
solar energy
in other words they should not be
allowed to use fossil fuels
or nuclear or hydroelectric
power to build the wind and solar
infrastructure and then see how fast it
disappears it would be wiped off the
face of the earth and
and goodly so because it is a parasite
and all these people are getting rich
all the crony capitalists are getting
rich off the subsidies they're first
there are subsidies then there are tax
breaks then there are mandates by
utilities that politically are forcing
the
people to take the wind and solar when
it's available even though it costs more
than the other technologies it's a total
mess and this is the part of climate
change that is worth paying attention to
the science of climate change i cover it
in my book thoroughly fake invisible
catastrophes and threats of doom
the main reason that we have all these
scare stories today is because there are
a lot of things that are either
invisible carbon dioxide radiation
whatever is supposed to be bad in gmos
which actually doesn't exist because it
doesn't have a name or a chemical
formula so therefore it's fake but co2
and radiation aren't fake they're just
invisible so no one can see what they're
doing
then you have the remote things polar
why are polar bears and coral reefs the
main icons here because no one can see
what they're doing
right so they say 93 of the great
barrier reef is nearly dead is
practically dead
is bleached is in its final terminal
stage none of those mean dead
of course they just they they make it
like practically dead it means it's
gonna die right no no it doesn't
things come back from being practically
dead like coral reefs
and they weren't practically dead in the
first place that was all hypen anyways
polar bear population has grown by four
to five times in the last 50 years
i ask big audiences of professional
people how many of you have heard of the
international treaty signed in 1973 by
all the polar nations ending the
unrestricted hunting of polar bears
no one's ever heard of it no one ever
talks about it they don't want you to
know about that because that treaty on
the advice of wildlife biologists to the
leaders of those countries around the
pole
that has caused a three to five times
increase in polar bear populations to
this day we're now the people who live
up in the polar bear region in canada
it's nunavut and then it's greenland and
norway those people in nunavut the which
is canada has the most polar bears of
anybody because we have so many islands
up there in the arctic
those people have passed a polar bear
management plan two years ago because
they think there's too many polar bears
because they're eating people
and
and they are breaking into houses and
there there's just too many of them
they've grown so much and yet not one
newspaper in canada or the united states
reported that polar bear management plan
or a report the treaty that was signed
in 1973.
can you ask my question yeah yeah um
let me ask so
i'm
i believe in the kiss principle keep it
simple stupid right so i'm listening to
everything i'm writing down numbers
greenhouse gas emissions i'm doing
science projects over here i'm doing
math rule of 72.
i think
and this might be a long question you
might there will go a couple different
directions here
it sounds like you have a marketing
problem and i had the same conversation
with the libertarians uh when we had the
libertarian roundtable debate they have
all these amazing ideas but
nothing breaks through because none of
their candidates
are charismatic or nobody's listening to
them so i'm gonna throw something your
way and by the way i agree with you on
that analysis okay well thank you so
much i am i am a
a country boy from the north of
vancouver island with a science phd and
i know how to write about it and talk
about it yeah well let's say you are
absolutely correct is it fair to say
that you're not a fan of the new green
deal is that fair to say yeah that's
fair okay let's so we'll go there is it
fair to say that you're not a fan of the
paris climate accords
is that fair to say okay i'm just
painting a picture for you
so but you know who is
okay and i'm just gonna go down some
names here and just throw them out there
and this will get to my point of the
question about the marketing problem we
all know greta thundberg you've turned
you know 16 year old girl whatever maybe
she's 18 now you got leonardo dicaprio
you got al gore you have um pharrell
robert redford
um mark ruffalo joaquin feel like sir
david attenborough elon musk you can
throw him in that category jaden smith
if you're familiar with him will smith's
son big uh advocate of the uh did i just
go there with you just say jaden
okay
jane fonda the point is you have all
these celebrities
on the other side of your argument
yes for the most except they know
nothing about sex okay but that's my
point yeah and then and this essentially
you just basically answered my question
they're doing great at marketing you
have them some of the most famous people
in the world saying
listen to us we know what we're talking
about and then you have dr patrick moore
for the most part not a household name
smart guy on the other side so who's on
your who can you recruit
you know much like hollywood or the
celebrities or the green new deal crew
the aoc crew who can you cr recruit to
be your biggest advocate to say oh it's
not just me it's not this smart canadian
scientist that's saying this it's x y z
a b c bing bing bing bing bing it's a
kind of even the playing field because
it sounds like you have the exact same
problem libertarians have all these
amazing ideas but it's lost in the echo
chamber and nobody's listening is that a
fair point you understand what i'm
saying here
yes i don't know about the libertarian
analogy but you're right the point is
they don't have a charismatic leader or
leader you're right you're right about
the celebrity
analogy
um
i i don't know how to parse society in
in a way to give a decent answer to that
except all i know is i've worked all my
life in the environmental field
i've seen how it has changed and gone
off on a course that it's gone off on
now
where it's taking advantage uh of this
situation of people being afraid that
they're killing their grandchildren
while they're driving their car
and there
there are really no celebrities on the
science side most of the people on on
the science side that think like i do
are scientists well you have someone
like bill nye out there he's i would say
you know celebrity scientist household
name yeah success a lot of the gen z
grew up with that guy
bill nye
um but the point is i know you're
shaking your head you're kind of bill
nye he's a joke a green new deal he's a
joke yeah paris climbing i don't know if
they're not saying this is who's
yes those aren't jokes the paris climate
deal is not a joke it's an international
treaty
and it's based on the idea that a one
degree more rise in global temperature
will be a a disaster crisis and
emergency which is so ridiculous if you
look at the history of the temperature
of the earth i mean we're actually at
the tail end of a 50 million year
cooling period at this point in the
place to see an ice age
and yet they're saying it's too hot i
mean it's that simple
but you i what do you do about fads and
cults and but who can popular roots to
well we have to get your message out we
have an essentially what i'm asking we
have an organization which is recruiting
it's called a co2 coalition it's based
in arlington virginia
greg wright stone is the executive
director he is a very smart geologist
who's who understands the ages of the
earth
and he also understands politics very
well we just had a really good win in
pennsylvania where a judge overturned
the pennsylvania greenhouse gas
initiative which was going to cost
billions of dollars and just like with
the recent supreme court decision on the
epa and co2
this is basically making the point that
these administrations the deep state
basically does not have the right to
overrule congress and to go beyond what
congress has approved this there's a
trend in that direction now and that is
a good trend and we are helping with
that with information directly to the
people who are making the decisions
so the co2 coalition here clint l is
it's a funny name but it's initials for
an a a global warming uh group in europe
mainly it is now got over a thousand
people
who are real scientists behind it and so
we are organizing but we are not
politicians we're we're just not born
and we're not movie stars
you know so it's it's not an easy road
to hoe but the truth surely will
eventually
come to the surface
uh especially if the climate doesn't
warm very much in the next while which
it hasn't been doing for the last while
so we don't really have any big trend of
warming going on as a matter of fact
western north america was colder this
spring and early summer than it has been
for a long time but those aren't the
messages we're hearing the media that
well they don't report cold they only
report hot
you know so that's the other problem
that is a societal problem and a
political problem is the vast majority
of the media is fake now and they're not
reporting the southern border they're
not reporting the climate news i see
politicians saying that bangladesh now
has the biggest flood in 100 years they
have floods every year a hundred people
have died this year in floods just a few
years ago 400 people died in floods and
they're saying it's the biggest in 100
years and these are canadian members of
parliament
is it the fact that the media is
actually fake or they more just have an
agenda and they want to stick to that
agenda in order there's a difference
there no in order to stick to their
agenda they must lie
that's what they're doing and they're
they know they're doing it
they absolutely know they're twisting it
and turning and ignore they have two
strategies one is to lie the other one
is to ignore so a combination of lying
and ignoring works really well at making
the population ignorant of what's really
going on in the world today because
what's going on in the world today
is that the air is healthy healthier
than it was 50 years ago or even 100
years ago or even 200 years ago when
they were burning coal in every house
you know they had they had the black
death in london occurred before 1900
when they finally realized they had to
stop using coal as their main fuel
and
all kinds of changes have happened which
make the air in the world cleaner today
the forest area of the of the world is
growing today as i mentioned china and
india are largely responsible but europe
as well and we're not losing forest
there's more forest in the united states
today than there was in 1900 by a small
margin but there is more
and that's because people are planting
trees because you see the more wood we
use people think oh the more wood we use
the fewer trees there will be no the
more wood we use the more trees there
will be
because when people use wood someone has
to plant another tree
in order to produce the wood for the
next person that wants it so building
all our house structures out of wood
actually is one of the main reasons why
we have so many trees here the reason
haiti has almost no forest is because
they build their houses out of
substandard concrete which falls on
their heads in an earthquake and killed
250 000 of them
after the japanese tsunami which killed
no one in the earthquake unfortunately
20 000 people died in the tsunami but
that wasn't because buildings failed
that was because of the wave the
buildings in japan are built to
standards that can withstand an
earthquake of nine
in haiti an earthquake 20 times less
less powerful killed a quarter of a
million people it's powerful right now
because
they built their houses out of wood that
is treated for termites it was easy
treatment for termite resistance in wood
if they would build their houses with
termite resistant wood they would have
forests all across the country like
their neighbor dominican republic has
it's a famous border between the two
from the satellite you can see haiti
completely deforested and the dominican
republic green and luscious can be i've
been there it's a beautiful place i'm
not going to haiti
it's funny you know for me the more we
do this is not my area of expertise i'm
just curious about it like it's
something i i want to
talk to more people to see opposing
ideas but the one thing that does
concern me is capacity that's the one
thing that concerns me and you see half
these guys that are using it's very easy
to use fear tactics with something that
can be made up it's very easy to use
this in marketing campaign
it's an easy gimmick
uh to use but the concern again for me
is capacity the world population that's
the part that concerns me because we're
two doubles away from 32 billion people
living here but you can see patrick that
it's self-controlling because if there's
too many people they won't be able to
live
and so then there won't be too many
people anymore now
it's a fine line because
possibly what will happen is the
population will continue to grow and
grow and grow
and then something will happen it'll get
cold and the crops will fail in the
north
and you'll have mass starvation that's
what happens has happened all through
the history of civilization yeah but so
then then there's two choices we have do
we just accept that and well you know
when it comes it comes or do we do
something about it today to educate to
prepare to
anticipate is is is it better to plan
the anticipation and preparation game or
is it better to sit there and say look
when that time comes and we starve and
half the population and the world dies
we'll adjust to it and we'll move
forward well that would be the case it's
with the case with all the animals and
all the plants and all the insects that
have to adjust to the changing climates
through the millions of years is that
the approach to proactive approach there
are plagues and you you're afraid of a
human plague i can understand that it
would be a plague is really when there's
more than can survive and then you have
a mass die-off once they've eaten
themselves out of house and home like
with locusts for example once they've
eaten all the crops there's nothing left
about them so that that kind of thing
could happen with humans i don't know if
i mean we are capable of planning
uh whereas a bear probably
i don't know they plan a little bit they
go and get into a den in the winter so i
guess that part of planning for them but
we can really plan in a serious way of
course but you have to wonder how far
you go from a draconian point of view
what do you force people to do not force
i don't think i'm saying force i'm
saying education yes i agree with that
and i think most people uh today would
agree with you that we
should not
over populate the earth okay but the
problem is what is the what is the
definition of overpopulation but what
i'm saying is you know if
if if the guys who are the phds of the
world i'm not the phd of the world but
if the phds of the world team up with
the business analytics of the world and
they pull up the formula
i guarantee you you guys can come with a
high low
i guarantee you can come up with a high
load to say this is the number guys
not if you take into account the fact
that there are going to be countless
innovations
into the future in health uh i know a
guy who's working on a procedure that
would prevent calcification in our veins
and that's the main reason people
eventually die is because of blood flow
in in your veins
a lot i mean people die of other things
before that happens sure but the reason
not many people live more than 105 or so
is because it just that's a natural
process that occurs and if you if you
think about it
death is an absolute necessity for
evolution because nothing would change
if nobody died
right
yeah that goes for birds and and plants
and everything right so the reason
that life has evolved to where it is
today is because of the cycle of birth
and death
and so we may be able though with our
chemistry and our medical knowledge to
make people live 200 years
then what happens now you've got
effectively got twice as many people
it's even worse well i don't know about
worse uh it would mean you'd want to
live 200 years it would mean well i
would who wouldn't no i'm fine okay well
good
but you want to live a little longer
than i i wouldn't mind i think 80 to 100
is fine with me yeah yeah i need you
guys
200 years old you live to you don't have
kids you live 200 years old i got to
watch a couple of my kids i'm good what
if you're 200 years old and still as
healthy as you are today though
um
i don't i i don't i think there is
uh
i think there is nobility in it's
somebody else's time and it's time for
you to move on to somebody else taking
over
i think there's nobility and honor in
that i don't i think it's too selfish to
want to
hold that kind of influence for that
long somebody else has their pruning
process is healthy anyways that's just
my fault i was saying that about
evolution yes it is healthy there has to
be a pruning process or nothing would
ever change other in other words
everything would still be microscopic
one-celled things in the ocean
i'd like to know what our audience has
to say would people in our audience want
to live past a hundred is that a goal
for most people a lot of people do but
you may want to comment that we'll
follow it down how many guys would like
to live
beyond a hundred beyond a hundred years
old two hundred i was just at a birthday
party for a hundred and forty year old
woman who has all her marbles and
doesn't have any walking 104. yeah she
still drives
well good for her
respect
where does she live in comox british
columbia i won't be driving around there
anymore i'm going to keep it over there
my mom's 94 and she still drives one
thing we know for she's got all our
marbles one thing we know for a fact
our friend here adam is not into older
women
his formula is half his age plus seven
that's a sweet spot so can we talk about
a couple different things can you bring
up i was just in texas this morning
uh i got in at 2 a.m this morning from
texas and i was in dallas
and it's funny we're eating at ocean air
and all of a sudden lights upstairs goes
out
and the guy comes up and he says look
this has nothing to do with the
blackouts and the power we're not
turning it off because we're trying to
save power here he joked about it i'm
like what's he talking about so then
here's the article texas texans asked to
conserve energy to protect the power
grid for the second time in a week
texans have been asked to turn up the
thermostats
and avoid using large appliances from 2
to 9 p.m wednesday
the power grid operator said it does not
expect rolling blackouts and i think the
temperature tyler if you want to go up
so i can read the rest is 78 there you
go 78 degrees for the second time this
week the state's power grid operator is
asking texans to turn up their
thermostats to 78 degrees and to avoid
using large appliances as it expected
record high demand for power grid
ongoing
scorching temperatures that is asking
for conservation two to nine pm
interesting so what do you what do you
think when you hear something like this
or you read some light something like
this i think in the southern states the
temperatures kept too low in most
buildings i think it's 78 is fine i set
mine 78. i set mine at 80. i and i come
from canada but i set my room at 80 here
because when i go outside it's 90. right
and if i come on i feel fine
people are going to hear these numbers
like what are you talking about sleep at
80. yeah i can sleep at 80. i just take
the covers on like can you sleep at 80.
hell no i'm a 72 guy it says what are
you on my thermostat about the number
right 72 when you said what 80. my i i
set it at seven i'm in miami buddy 80
are you kidding me i want to feel cool
when i sleep are you are you telling me
that people in texas should disregard
what they're saying and just keep their
thermostat at 80. no no they should put
it at 78 like they say 78 yeah nobody's
doing that man no i know they're not but
nobody
when you're from the north right
you you set your thermostat
probably at 75.
people most people would set it at 75 or
even or even lower it's true but that's
because it's way colder outside eight
months out of the year you don't even
use the ac no you use the heater well i
don't we only have ac in our bedrooms we
don't have the rest of the house okay
condition just open the windows but what
about our friends in texas and yeah what
is it urcot e-r-c-o-t is that no that's
the whole like
the real stupid thing about this is
they're running out of power in texas
one of the richest places in the world
and the reason they're having this
problem is because of the huge amount of
wind power they put in
because it just isn't there sometimes
a lot a lot of the time it just isn't
there
and and this is where people are going
texas australia new york
ontario in canada
germany
all these countries are going to come up
against this wall
because they just keep building more
wind and solar the plans to build
offshore upstate new york and off long
island there there's plans to build like
vast wind farms offshore now they're
worried about the right whales being in
because white whales give have their
birthing up north of there and then come
south and they're going to have to be
navigating through this massive bunch of
wind turbines to get out of there uh
maybe it's a made-up thing i mean i
think right whales can probably get past
wind farms but let me ask you a quick
question wrong thing is the wind farm in
the first place
maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm
misinterpreting this but you know in in
economics there's a term laissez faire
uh economics right where don't do
anything just let
free market capitalism take its place no
government interference whatsoever just
it is what it is let it be what it be is
that essentially the argument that
you're making for
climate change or the environment is do
nothing let let it be what it be am i
misinterpreting that i spent a great
part of my life stopping toxics from
going into the air and water
uh
there has to be rules okay but but when
the epa made the ruling that co2 was air
pollution instead of recognizing that it
was the main food of all life on earth
that was a big mistake and they did it
without
congress giving them the authority to do
that and that's been ruled
against by the supreme court now which
is a really good decision
like what that did was it gave the epa
the power to determine the entire energy
infrastructure and what technology could
and could not be used nothing to do with
clean air
the air that we we can burn coal clean
now it's being done even in china
they're putting good pollution control
on their coal plants but when you make
co2 a pollutant
the food of life
that's abso absolutely nuts co2 is not a
pollutant what else is on your checklist
like if you're saying all right no don't
do laissez-faire for the environment
like there's some things you should do
is there a certain like 3.5 point
checklist do this do this do this like
you talked about well don't co2 what
else it's the don't do's that matter
don't murder people don't don't abuse
people you know don't but that's don't
you know we've known about that since
the ten commandments i'm talking about
government interference today
what should
be done
well there's no clear answer to that
question it's
it's what shouldn't be done to a large
extent what shouldn't be done is calling
carbon dioxide carbon any just remember
this anybody who calls co2 carbon don't
listen to a word they say
because co2 is not carbon it is carbon
dioxide we don't call water hydrogen
water is hydrogen dioxide right i
learned that from the water boy shout
out to adam's salmon so you don't call
it hydrogen just because it's the first
letter in the in the formula so these
people are calling it carbon because
they want you to think of soot
right well why don't they want you to
think of diamonds because that's pure
carbon too and so is graphite what our
pencils have in them carbon is a miracle
element
and co2 is a miracle molecule because
all the carbon in all life comes from
co2 in the air and the ocean
that's where it comes from and fossil
fuels are made with carbon that came
from life so all the fossil fuels were
made with solar energy
have you heard that before
no well how else did the oil and gas are
from marine animals and the coal is from
forests on the land
they were made with solar energy
that's the basis of all life turning
carbon dioxide and water into sugar and
then the sugar is the energy for all of
life from there on up to us
all life
and if we threaten our own food system
with these stupid rules about not using
nitrogen or carbon dioxide maybe they're
going to ban carbon dioxide in
greenhouses the next thing you know
people are working in there in co2
levels two and three times what it is in
the atmosphere and actually right in
this room now co2 will be at least
double what it is out in the air
because of our breathing we breathe out
two pounds of co2 every day
and the you know the atmosphere is now
420 parts per million co2 when we exhale
it's 40 000 parts per million co2
because we're taking in oxygen and
breathing out co2 the plants take in co2
and breathe out oxygen so it's a perfect
cycle
and that's how that's nature in a
nutshell
and people are not being even educated
about that
never mind about basic chemistry and
biology
and the the fact the matter is is the
earth is very healthy at its present
state there is great to hear there's we
we always hear there's no planet b that
the earth is dying that's not dying but
the oceans are being overfished in many
places because of inter you hear that
all the time well it's international
waters there's no governance there
and for example canada and the united
states have a treaty with china sorry
with japan and russia over the salmon
in the north pacific so we do have
governance there about how many we can
take and what we can do there's quite a
few of these treaties uh that one who's
the biggest culprit in overfishing in uh
in the international waters
japan china spain portugal uh
i mean maybe i haven't got the top four
there but and who's holding these
countries accountable
well they make their own rules in
international waters like for the reason
they were able to kill 30 000 whales a
year big whales a year in the north
pacific japan and russia were both
involved in that with big factory fleets
before we got out there for four years
and got in front of the harpoons and got
on television all around the world and
it was finally ended by the
international whaling commission which
is an arm of the united nations
and so
that we succeeded but it was very
difficult because there there really
there wasn't a sense a governing body
the international whaling commission but
it was totally ruled by the whaling
countries
so we did a political uh
movement where we recruited island
nations to join the international
whaling commission
ones that wanted to stop the whaling and
we got a majority on the iwc
uh
back then we didn't want to admit that
was what was going on because some
people thought that was unfair
especially the guys that were killing
the whales
but uh there's two stories i want to
touch before we apparently we have one
of our guys vincent o'shanna
who's uh actor and a comedian we hired
i'm not going to go to him right now i'm
going to go to him in about 12 minutes i
think
he's in a very strange place yeah he's
here he's just texting me right here
okay all right we're going to we're
going to go through he's going to go to
him in about 15 minutes but let's stick
to two stories okay
one you commented about trump earlier i
want to get your feedback on this this
just happened over the weekend if you
want to prepare the tweet
uh both of them trump's uh first message
of what he said and then the follow-up
from how elon responded and what then
trump put the day after so let me read
this article to you guys
trump ramps up feud with the llamas
claiming he would have made elon musk
drop to his knees and beg for help
uh when he was president
uh originally uh so on tuesday morning
trump uh
penned the three posts hitting that musk
just the day before day after musk
tweeted that it was time for mr
president to sail into the sunset when
elon musk came to the white house asking
me for help
on all of his many subsidy projects
whether it's electric cars that don't
drive long enough driverless cars that
crash or rocket ships to nowhere
without uh which subsidies he'd be
worthless and telling me how he was big
a big trump fan and republican i could
have said drop to your knees and beg and
he would have done it
trump claimed in a post and by the way
the day prior to that he was given a
message a speech
and he called elon musk a bullshitter
[ __ ] artist yeah and then musk
responded
and said uh there there needs to be a
maximum age for presidency after trump
publicly criticized musk calling him a
[ __ ] artist at a rally in anchorage
alaska musk tweeted that he thinks it's
time for trump to hang it up and sail
into the sunset in a series of tweets
musk said he does not hate trump but
that his days at the forefront of
politics should be done musk also
suggested democrats were enabling
trump's potential return to the white
house which he said should also stop a
twitter use user then ask must what
issues he had with trump's presidency to
which he replied yeah but too much drama
do you really want to
a bull in a china shop situation every
single day musk then suggested that the
legal maximum age to start a
presidential term should be 69 years old
which is one thing we talked about 35 to
69. uh so that's the going back and
forth to two of them what is your take
on trump going after elon musk you got a
lot of people to go after why go after
elon musk time for musk you're for musk
yeah i think trump should disappear into
the sunset uh
all the circumstances that have happened
i can't
i can understand why he is miffed about
what happened to him through his
presidency he was attacked every day
every day all day i still think the
policies he brought in were worthy and i
still think what biden did to them is
wrong if you look at the just the
southern border and the energy issue and
afghanistan and on and on
i i believe
he tried to do the right thing during
his presidency but he is a bull in the
china shop
and it would be a good idea if someone
less
like that such as
desantis desantis by the way it's so
funny you're saying that this is this
very important that you took the angle
that you took because trump tweeted
about you
i want to say in 16 i don't know the
exact date but he said patrick moore
co-founder of green space
greenpeace
uh the whole climate crisis is not only
fake news it's fake science there's no
climate crisis there's weather and
climate all around the world and in fact
carbon dioxide is the main building
blocks of life
wow
and then uh who made that quote you or
him i made he quoted me he quoted him so
i put it on the back of my book because
i i i wasn't quoting him he was quoting
me that's right
i thought that's fine so he's a fan of
yours apparently and you want him out of
you don't want him to run for president
again i didn't say that uh if he decides
to reset the sail off in the sunset yes
that's what
if i was him that's what i would do but
i am not him and i'm not i don't have
that temperament
uh maybe he does why do you say that's
what he should do if you're and again
you're an advocate it seems because
i think it's too polarized
[Music]
and i think he's part of the reason why
it is and i think he did a good job when
he was in office but he would have done
a much better job if they hadn't
impeached him twice and put him through
that whole mueller investigation which
was all phony baloney so you know you
you look back in history
and you look at the situation now and i
would have said something different back
then probably i would have said can
carry on
but
he shouldn't get into these kind of
myths
with elon musk elon musk is pretty good
he's he's he yes he panders to the
climate issue to a certain extent but
who doesn't well that's right what
helped him become the richest man in the
world exactly but but you know you know
what's the crazy thing about this here's
where i don't uh uh understand his
strategy and i tweeted about this couple
days ago people were all upset i was
like i can't believe you did this whose
side are you and i said i'm not i'm not
trying to make more friends i'm just
telling you how i process this because
so you say this about musk
he's the lead today as a republican and
it's not even close i think it's like 46
is him 29 is uh
desantis and then i think it drops to
seven percent cruise and i think it's
six percent is pence and nikki he's
still the guy in the republicans so
check this out so you make a comment
about a guy that's got 100 million
twitter followers and you're not on
twitter he's on twitter
rogan a week ago just said he would
never have you on then musk says this
and you go after musk so let's just say
let's let's play this out
let's say trump is the candidate for the
republican side let's say he is let's
say he wins
you think musk is the kind of a guy that
would flip and say oh we have to vote
for trump
you think musk is all of a sudden going
to get behind trump we think muscle is
going to remember what he said when he
called him a [ __ ] artist what kind
of a wiring do you think mosque has you
think musk is going to sit there and say
well let's get him in there or he's
going to say [ __ ] why are you putting me
in this guy you cornered musk to not
support you
that's why i do that
like that's why by the way i did not
trust you
but you summed up exactly what i'm
thinking if there's like you talk about
this all the time don't create
unnecessary enemies it's a game of
conversion it's a game of math let's say
you're at 48 you want to get the 52 of
the country to support you because
that's how close these elections are no
sense you're creating unnecessary
enemies you're supposed to be building
advocates and building allies and you're
taking arguably two of the most popular
men in america approval ratings
considered
elon musk and joe rogan by the way who
are allies within each other right those
guys are in touch and you're cornering
these guys to basically say he's
untouchable yeah it doesn't make sense
to me and this is the problem that
people have for trump it's like make
these guys your allies not your enemies
or at the very least be neutral
let me know
nothing nothing you can understand why
trump is bitter but he is bitter and
that doesn't look good no it's not
attractive you don't you when he was
saying make america great again it
wasn't from a place of bitterness it was
a from places this is friends
it was it was from a different place but
but you should read that but you know
what it is here's a question you gotta
ask yourself okay here's a question i
got and i asked this i said and i put
that in the tweet afterwards i said
i said the only way this makes sense is
the following way the only way to go go
back to my tweet it's part two the only
way this makes sense is if
his concern is more to increase
valuation of truth social over him
becoming president
maybe that's his agenda but by the way
let me unpack that in case anybody if in
case there's a one percent chance of
this being true which
99 it's not if it is
president trump just so you know
the day comes where the world is
celebrating your funeral and and your
service to whatever you did in humanity
somebody that became very successful in
business and media and you were a
controversial figure that became a
president your policies were effective
but you you know people hated you you
had a lot of different things that
happened no one's gonna care whether you
die
being worth three billion dollars ten
billion dollars a hundred million
dollars and i'm willing to say even if
somehow some way you're worth 300
billion dollars that reputation of
business nothing's gonna change
you winning one more time and coming
back and being able to redeem yourself
that's the true legacy and you're
hurting yourself when you do stuff like
this this to me made no sense with so so
i don't know what i'm saying so let's
just say the smack of truth social goes
and he sells it for 20 billion
and he's 38 owner he gets you know 7.6
billion
who gives a [ __ ]
who cares yeah so you so what you got
another 7.6 billion dollars i'm 100
you're basically saying the bigger
challenge is your legacy who gives a
[ __ ] if you have a couple more real
estate in the most competitive
environment new york and the most hey
you you came up and you had all this
stuff always daddy's son you left the
other side to go make it in manhattan
your name trump is all over hotels then
you have a reality tv show then you go
out there and become a president like
who's who's been able to do that's like
saying you're a trifecta you know like
this guy can dance he can sing you can
act yeah dude you won in business you
wanted media and you won in politics
what are you talking about how many
people like that are there not many what
are you doing anyways but are you
getting a lot of hate for basically
calling trump out here look i i'm not i
don't wake up in the morning saying what
do i need to do to get a lot of likes
i wake up in the morning saying this is
how i'm processing this you agree
disagree this is me you do what you got
to do this is my beliefs and make a
decision for yourself i'm not i'm not
advocating for you to leave
valuetainment to become a an advisor to
trump but someone like you
is what someone like trump is missing
someone to say dude i'm on your team and
you're and you're a trump fan i mean
it's i don't think that's secrets
policies are yes unbelievable just like
doctor or more over here but at the same
time you're gonna be like dude what are
you doing yeah this doesn't make sense
and that's the problem that trump has is
there's no one saying dude i'm with you
i'm on your team i want you to succeed
don't pick fights with these types of
people it does not serve you this is
only going to hurt you
but
bull in a china shop yeah
it's a it's a little wild situation but
i had two other stories i wanted to get
into but i got i got dream team call
today so i can't do it and by the way so
everybody knows at this point we hired
this new you know friend of ours vincent
o'shannon who's an actor and a comedian
was part of deaf comedy jam i think
kevin hart interviewed him they did a
lot of different work so when when he
came on board to the valuetainment team
i said look one of the things we can do
is i'd like to see you go around the
world go around different places and you
know where we can find out where's
vinnie and he's going so up
is it true what i just got in text
tell me this is fake i've been told
apparently tell me this is fake no
apparently can we go to vinnie real
quick yeah hey i think vinnie is live
right now hey vinnie is where is vinnie
now vinnie is it is it true that what
mario just text me what room you're in
get the hell out of here hold on what is
it in nancy pelosi's office i can't see
the picture can you get a little closer
you're in nancy pelosi's office
we came to washington to make videos for
valuetainment we did a tour of the
capitol and her door was always listen
bro your mom's going to kill me if she
says you hire my son and he goes to jail
what is this guy doing
my mom hates her too but look look at
look how loose
and then look at that
number one i think you should get the
hell out of there but while you're there
see what's in the desk would you
yeah okay i think he drank the other
half of that bottle adam look look oh my
god
be quiet this is what nancy's got
i'll bet
out don't stay there tonight okay all
right
look at this
insider training for dummy yeah no [ __ ]
oh
and then look
the art of the deal was
why is he making this well put that
nancy despite what we show the public i
can't wait for us to make america great
again it's going to be huge your dear
friend
trump vinnie
this is
how did he get in there pat
mario can you like are we okay with this
or
holy moly am i implicated oh my god he
said that he was taking a tour of they
went to washington first of all he's
going to dc because he's meeting a
friend yeah he was meeting a girl from
back in the days he was going to go to
dc and then
man i mean he got luck it is what it is
this would be to short-live the job that
he got he just came in [ __ ] that's not
good uh but the insider trading and the
art of the deal what are the odds that
of the two books that he finds there's
insider trading for dummies in the art
of the deal but i can't see her reading
that book it's actually pretty good book
for her to read art of the deal you can
tell them when she comes down to
negotiating she's pretty hardcore well
anyways hopefully we got vinnie out of
there somebody text me and tell me
vinnie the moment you're out just text
me i need to know you're safe and you're
in a good place uh i guess we got 10
more minutes with another story just can
you please zoom in on patrick's face
right yeah doctor
this was our plan
valuetainment with the heart and there's
no clue what's going on he's not faking
it is he no no we're just there we just
went from having all these
crazy serious conversations then we talk
about trump tonight we see vinnie is uh
look i mean if this if this
this story breaks
just so everybody knows in the public in
case you write about it dr patrick moore
had nothing to do with it he's just a
guest today he's not you're but you you
promised to incorporate me in this
somehow yeah in your publicity you know
maybe then i'll be able to get through
this and there you go that's marketing
101
but yeah this guy vinnie he's sick in
the head i i can't number one i hope he
gets
out of the capital unscathed no problems
i hope he doesn't go to jail i hope he's
going to be okay but i can't wait to see
where vinnie is next where is vinny now
i think it could take off hopefully if
he doesn't end up in jerusalem
look what they did to the january six
people yeah
is he gonna be in solitary well those
people did some some damage to her
office so vinnie hopefully didn't do
that yeah maybe he leaves like a nice no
thank you for your time here or
something like that be safe out there
we've got ten minutes can we do two more
stories sure ten minutes i want to talk
about sri lanka so sri lanka has been a
bit of a mess lately i know you've been
fi it's actually it's mess but it's also
good where the people are finally
standing up against the government to
say look we're sick of this
so uh uh uh which page is it on sale
bottom of five bottom of five okay let
me go to the bottom of five
all right so leaked security video from
inside rob elementary school no this is
not it this is uh
what story are you on i am on bottom of
five
sri lanka deleted article right here i'm
on fire maybe next maybe it's the next
uh
no this says five so give me your five
yes
sir okay let me read this to you so
there's no one over there deleted wf
article sri lanka pm uh a prim prime
minister this is how long i will make my
country rich by 2025. we have achieved
many positive gains over the last three
years through both policy initiatives
and pragmatic strategies that enable the
country to win back recognition and
friendly engagement with the rest of the
world this has been a key foreign policy
achievement of our government the plan
is delivering impressive results the
current government has created over 460
000 jobs helped more than 260 000
families secure homes strong progress is
being made
on plans to bring opportunities to rural
communities by building necessary
infrastructure such as road bridges
connecting brutal and urban areas and
linking sri lanka economic hubs a
program enterprise uh sri lanka anyways
and then eventually that leads to
why sri lanka is facing one of the worst
economic crisis the island nation of sri
lanka is in the midst of one of the
worst economic crisis it's ever seen it
has defaulted on its foreign debts for
the first time since its independence
and the countries 22 million people are
facing crippling 12-hour power cuts
and an extreme scarcity of food fuel and
other essential time items such as
medicines in march 2020 the coba 19
pandemic struck in april 2021 rajapaksa
government made another fatal mistake to
prevent the drain of foreign exchange
reserves all fertilizer imports were
completely banned sri lanka was declared
a 100 organic
farming nation this policy which was
withdrawn in november 2020 led to
drastic fall on agriculture production
and more imports became necessary but
foreign exchanges reserves and we went
under uh strain a fall on the
productivity tea and rubber due to the
banner fertilizer also led to power
export incomes you guys saw the people
were the the
uh tyler if we can pull this up where
there was uh protesting going on in the
prime minister's house they're jumping
in the pool in the backyard and then
they're going up to the
what what are you what are you are you
following the story on what's going on
with sri lanka what are your thoughts on
what's going on there uh
social breakdown is almost inevitable
un unless some miracle happens because
the president and
and his
flunkies have all fled they're on a boat
somewhere out in the ocean
uh
and uh the people are occupying his his
palace
but i don't think there's any leadership
there now they don't have the fertilizer
they need to grow their food and sri
lanka is a very big food producing
country there's a lot of millions of
people there
and so this is the first bellwether of
the self-suicide destruction of these
elites
who i don't know where they get this
idea that there's too much nitrogen
uh in the soil or in the water
nitrogen is is again one of the building
blocks of life and and just like with
carbon dioxide and so you you've got now
netherlands the
the president or prime minister whatever
he is of netherlands
is saying they have to have make make a
third of their animals go away
which provides a lot of the manure for
fertilizing the crops and then they are
also going to ban part of the nitrogen
fertilizer for the crops and as i
mentioned earlier
the the process of making synthetic
ammonia is why
there are many more billions of people
alive today than there would have been
if that hadn't happened it those two
nobel prizes that were given to dr haber
and bosch haber invented the process and
bosch
built it up to an industrial scale so
millions of tons
of fertilizer could be produced around
the world and all farmers in the world
are dependent on this fertilizer for
making their crops grow faster and and
bigger and so if this if this cascades
like netherlands is getting a little
close to home it's happening in western
europe that leaders of governments are
banning
fertilizer
and
as i say uh core blund has a great uh
country singer in canada has a song
about
have you ever seen a a a a child who
hasn't eaten in 18 days
and uh
you know we can live without food for
longer than we can without water and we
can live without water long longer than
we can without air
but there is a limit with food too and
mass starvation is not a pretty thing
and it's happened all through human
history we haven't had much of it lately
because we've been on a roll
in terms of technology and agricultural
innovation and producing more food and
doubled the population like we see
but that doesn't necessarily go on
forever and it would be a shame if it
was a self-inflicted wound
uh oh it's okay okay
let's let's at least not shoot ourselves
in in in the midsection here uh that's
what i see happening and
food shortages are not something that
are easily caught up with there are such
things as seasons
and there are such things as
how much you can grow in a certain area
of land and if you don't have fertilizer
you're only going to get half as much
and pretty soon the store shelves are
going to start being empty in some parts
of the world and hopefully we're
we're in we're in a much better position
in north america than
most other places in the world in many
ways
but
this can come this can happen anywhere
if if people start deciding to ban
carbon dioxide and nitrogen which are
what life is made from
you know it's crazy i i when i saw this
i i wrote this out on twit on twitter i
said if the world allows a country with
a 81 billion gdp go bankrupt so can
america allow the too big to fail
companies fail soon bad policies created
by bad leaders caused countries to go
bankrupt the people of sri lanka were
sick of gotobaya rajapaska's democratic
socialist policies and they moved on
right they're saying they don't like it
now here's what's crazy
a guy responds back to this tweet and he
says
he says you're not going to find it but
if you go you'll find it because there's
a bunch of them to go through he says
well that has nothing to do with their
democratic socialist policies and then
one guy responds that's a great thing
about twitter when people have a debate
they're going to solve each other's
issues he says i'm sorry what do you
mean he says that's not has nothing to
do with democratic socialist policies
can you go to sri lanka's uh wikipedia
please go to sri lanka's wikipedia what
does this say on the top right
democratic to the top right right right
democratic rights republicans can you go
to the right yeah democratic socialist
republic of sri lanka that's long hand
for communism yes that's exactly it
folks if you hear
anybody in america pitch that to you and
they seem noble eventually you'll be
doing that 5 10 15 years later realizing
that whoa that vote was a shitty vote
just like right now we're facing some
consequences with inflation just came
out yesterday being 9.1 percent
inflation came out yesterday 9.1 percent
you know what inflation was in december
of 2020 do you know what inflation was
at december of 20.
no no it was 1.4 1.7
okay if you pull up right now was on the
article
inflation
just two years ago
december of 2020. you can actually look
this up it was 1.4 percent okay i was
off by 0.2
then it went up to 1.7 then 4.2 then 5.4
the month that putin invades ukraine it
was 7.9 which means they can't blame
putin even pre-putin it was at 7.9 now
it's 9.1
inflation
and uh who pays the price for this do
the billionaires pay the price for this
no do the rich pay the price for this no
who pays the price for this the worst
low income middle income families who
are going out there working a job making
15 20 30 bucks an hour trying to take
care of their families and they're
paying a price for this because they're
filling in in the gas station they're
filling it everywhere now biden sent a
tweet out yesterday responding to
inflation i don't know if you have that
one up or not if you do real quick this
is what biden said after the inflation
numbers came up he said if you can zoom
in a little bit more uh energy companies
nearly half of today's inflation numbers
so here's what's important energy loan
comprises nearly half of today's
inflation numbers the price of gas has
increased 30 days straight decreased
decreased i'm sorry decreased 30 days
straight the price at the pump has
dropped by 40 cents since mid-june
gas should continue to come down in the
days and work weeks ahead here's a crazy
thing here's a crazy thing
he's the president can you go back to
that tweet
a president sends a tweet and he gets 17
000
likes
this is not a tick tocker
this is the president
that got 17 000 you know what 17 800
likes
that's like you putting the tweet and
you get two likes
i got over three thousand uh
retweets just the other day and i've got
you're not the president i guess 2500
today this guy's the president
and can you go to the other one about
inflation go to the other one about
inflation that we got today's uh report
is uh inflation too high yeah uh
fighting inflation is my top economic
priority and while the numbers today are
not acceptable they're also outdated in
the past 30 years the average price of
gas is okay so he's trying to put that
message in there's 30 000 likes on that
so that's
making some progress it's like i'm
telling you do you know what this
reminds me of
where is will ferrell when he was making
fun of bush will ferrell how come you're
not doing it with biden biting is a
hundred times easier to make fun of than
when you were making part of bush when
he came out and said you know president
bush you know
i'm here in crawford texas growing my
soul patch hanging out with connie and
dick but we're keeping our eyes on the
ball and and we're
we're focused on climate change and bc
the rays are intensifying in such a way
where the lava flows in in in is cut i'm
not gonna lie to you i don't know what
the hell i'm talking about i mean let
the boy
watch is what you're trying to say right
now what i'm trying to say is will
ferrell come on man come on win
fair and do a joe biden impersonation
promise you it'll be better than
uh the bush impersonation anyways we had
a lot of fun today we talked about a lot
did we mention my book yet no let's do
that so let's wrap it up fake invisible
catastrophes and threats of doom by
patrick moore available on amazon it has
2
300 reviews which is more than most
books ever get and it's only been out
for a year it has really good ratings 95
of all my ratings are four and five star
for the book it's easy to read and it
will give you a whole bunch of
information beyond what i've talked
about today tyler can we put that in the
description and in the comments section
it's available in all four of those
formats kindle audiobook hardcover and
paperback well we're gonna drive towards
that dr patrick moore thank you so much
for coming out and uh uh educating us
and challenging and being open to the
push back and going through it i uh
i'm sure all of us got smarter just by
having you on the podcast today because
i'd be scared there for a while no i
just want
for me when i bring somebody that's
smart i want to kind of get them to the
course so i learned that's how i learned
i'm trying to learn from you and i was
able to do that which was a successful
podcast once again appreciate you for
coming i enjoyed it greatly thank you
thank you dr
thank you very much have a good one
everybody have a great weekend we'll do
it again next week take care bye bye bye
you